today I'm going to talk about our tool
to extract data from text
um
so I'm going to start by stating the
problem that we are going to solve then
I'm going to present our approach and
then I'm going to dive into the details
of our approach namely tagging querying
and projection and then David is going
to present to give a demo with the
Jupiter notebook and he will wrap up the
presentation with conclusions
so what is the problem that we are
trying to solve here so we have text and
then we are trying to extract some data
from that text and then for example in
what you see in the screen here say we
have a text representing with the
statement of a of a financial
institution and then our tool allow us
to retrieve a specific data from that
text and then produce say a Json
document
so what is our approach what we are
going to do is we start with text but
the first thing that we are going to do
is we are going to annotate that text
with tags so for example we can tag
every single line in the text with with
the tagline and then we can also say tag
all the integers that appear in the text
and then in addition to that we can also
tag a specific string so we want the
occurrence of a specific strain extreme
say for example electricity delivery and
rate change this billing period then
once we have the tax then we can use
these tags to query the document and get
the results so let's look at an example
suppose that we want this box here the
result the text in this green box here
so what we need is select the text
between the line that starts with
electricity derivative that means this
line that they start with the blue and
the string rate change this billing
period so it's going to extract this
text here
so as I
presented in our approach the first step
is to talk how do we tack the data there
so we basically tags associate is attack
attack with some locations in the
document so for example the tag integer
we can associate the tax integer with
all the strings in the text that match a
regular expression like at this regular
expression 0 9 plus or we can tack all
the integers like that way now
um
another possibility is sometimes you
don't wanna have to talk every single
thing so for example you have a string
like electricity delivery you don't want
to create attack for electricity
delivery so you can just anonymously say
okay give me give me all the occurrences
of this string so that's another
possibility so now
how do we represent a location a
location is defined as a triple
that has an offset a star and an at the
end typically the opposite is the
beginning from the beginning of the text
but later on we can see I'm going to
present uh an application where we will
be nice to have another type of offset
but this the the so if the offset is
zero that means that the star and the
end
is with reference to the beginning of
the text
so so once we have the tax so we'll
start doing the query so the query is
going to do in three steps so it's going
to be a pipeline so the first one we are
going to select a set of locations and
then once we have those set of location
tuples we set off tuples so we set up
location Tuple and then once we have the
set of location tablets we can apply a
function to each Tuple of the step one
and then we can apply the function to
the results of the step two so we I am
going to illustrate that with an example
okay so the first step select the top of
location so for that we can use the
Tuple relational calculus so here what
we are going to select is a tuple of n
locations such that
each location below to attack so for
instance location one is intact one
location n is intact n in addition to
that we have a predicate that is going
to constrain further
what locations we are going to be
considering
so what is that predicate the predicate
is going to be conjunctions at the
junction of relations or locations so
what kind of relations or locations are
we talking about we have built-in and
user defined so for the built-in let's
consider the Allen's relations for
internet
so one possibility here we have
location X and location y so the before
is going to be true if location X is
before location y the mids if location X
is before is is half occurred before
location why but they are adjacent and
so forth in addition to that the user
can Define their own
relations to include in the query
okay so now
um so let's look at an example
so the example that we have here so
let's try to do the step one for the
example before so the step one first of
all we need to figure out what locations
we are interested so here we don't we
don't care about internet so we are
interested in lines in electricity
delivery and in rate change this billion
period so the location one is going to
be in line location two electricity
delivery and location three is rate
change this billing period and then we
need to constrain those locations
further so for example we want the
electricity no we don't want all the
lines only we want the line that starts
with the blue here so we want the line
that starts with electricity delivery so
that's what the Stars location to
location one will tell me and the other
is we want this line
we want the red part here the red change
this billing period to happen after this
line so the line should appear before
the rate change this billing period and
that's what this predicate is going to
tell you so what will be the result here
will be the result of a tuple of
relational we don't care about for the
result we don't care about the
electricity delivery we care it's about
the line where the electricity delivery
is so the result is going to be pairs
pairs of the line
where electricity delivery is and the
location
of the red
so but that is going to tell me two
locations but I'm interested is the
location of the text in between
so for that
I go to the next step
and thus when I apply here to the result
the location one and location three I
apply the function in between and there
are multiple functions so one is in
between that given two
intervals here two locations is going to
give me the location in between and
there that always like open right this
pan close the span low open left span
and others
but then
we might need a step three so for this
I'm going to modify the example a little
bit to illustrate this one so support
that we have two occurrences of rate
change this billing period so we have
one here and one here so when we are
asking for the text between electricity
delivery and the rate change so we are
going to have one possibility here in
yellow and the other possibility is from
here the yellow and the green one also
because it will be from here to here
so
in this case how do I pick up only the
the one that is closer so only the green
one so for that I apply the function
choices so the the function chart this
will allow me to select of all the
possible outputs here the in between is
going to give me all the possible
locations I'm going to select the
shortest but how do I select the
shortest eliminating all the locations
that are a superset of the others
okay so now early on we talk about a
location that has an offset so if we
consider this table if we consider the
offset for from the beginning of the
text so of course City Boston Los
Angeles and San Diego they are not going
yes excuse me we're running out of time
oh
yeah thank you thank you so these three
they are going to all of these they are
not going to intersect because all of
them are defined with respect to the
offset of the beginning of the text but
what if my offset is defined from the
beginning
of the line where the word happens so in
that case City Boston and Los Angeles
and San Diego they will overlap
and then these specific operation of
just changing the offset to say to the
beginning of the line would allow me to
identify columns and tables
okay so now I think uh I will pass this
to my colleague David Barrett so he can
show us a demo about how to use this
tool in Python
thank you thank you very much
and now uh we're going to introduce Mr
Davis hello hi can you hear me all right
yes so
um sir David Barrett uh he earned uh his
P after earning his PhD uh he has been
teaching and applying results for from
computer science research to engineer
solutions for large scale large-scale
software problems for the uh last 20
years
his expertise include machine learning
software systems networks databases
programming languages and compiler
construction
and uh the stage is yours thank you
thank you so much
so now at this point I'll be introducing
a python notebook we have on our release
for assistance we've pasted our code we
have our code available in GitHub and
the URL shown above and we also to run
our code you just go ahead and take to
use our code you just do a pip install
kante to go ahead and be able to use the
code at our packages and the stupider
notebook is actually part of the GitHub
distribution and it's available on
GitHub and if you download the code
so the first thing I'll show is that we
have two different examples we're going
to be running to illustrate the
capabilities of our tool and how to use
it the first example is to extract
emails from headers that are contained
in the body of email which turns out to
be a kind of complicated problem because
headers could appear in so many
different ways so in this case we're
going to try to extract emails dates and
times from the headers of the body in as
the text shown in green
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to import our package of the
items we need and we have several
different modules in our code the
modules are available to different
different functionalization required
this uh this Jupiter notebook also uses
some code for regular expressions for
dates times and emails from a local
module that we'll just go ahead and
import and then we can go ahead and
proceed to use those those Imports as
appropriate so the first thing we're
going to do is uh read the text from a
tagger read the text from the file that
we got from from the emails and then
we're going to go ahead and construct a
tag or object which allows us to go
ahead and evoke some sort of methods to
be able to place tags on the text that
we've just read
and that's the tagged email
the next thing we're going to be able to
do is do the tags as Market indicated
and the first the first thing we're
going to do is we're going to find we're
going to create tags for dates times
emails and then a more obscure thing
called a sent date time and then we're
going to use the tag re method to be
able to do that tag re takes a tag name
on the left in this case for example
date and then a regular expression on
the right which is a symbol that's
defined in our local module that just
defines a regular expression for what
dates look like and that's the second
parameter tag already same thing for
dates times and emails and then the last
thing is we have a special regular
expression which we Define explicitly
here percent or date because the headers
if you'll notice the second line of the
head the third line of the header on the
top header could be ascent and the third
line Second Line the bottom header could
be date and we'd like to just be able to
grab the time from that without worrying
about where it appears in the header
so we have a tagged re for Ascent date
time to do that so now we've got four
tags which we're then going to use the
predicate
so the predicate appears at the bottom
which is the
language that Martha mentioned earlier
and then we're going to have the
predicate's actually going to reference
some of the tags that we we've defined
above and so the first part is to find
that the tag is going to be referenced
by there's a nine Tuple that appears at
the top we've assigned it to tags and
the tags consist of a sequence of these
tags we have a literal from email a
greater than symbol set daytime date
time and email and so if you go back to
the headers you'll see that that those
tags actually follow the convention of
the orders of the top the from onset to
subject lines that we've seen here
okay
so the key here is is that the the
predicate is going to reference the tags
in the same order by the index numbers
as they appeared in the tags list that
was passed as the first parameter to the
query function that's coming up in a
second
and so seek before beats is basically
requiring that the tags appear in order
they could be possibly adjacent and then
we are going to make some constraints on
the the text so that we don't grab extra
stuff so for example this 0 comma eight
less than 350 prevents one header from
matching the content from another
and then the subsequent disks are
required the from and the two lines
email addresses to be to respectively
select the correct ones
so once we have the tag tags and the
predicate and then we have the tag email
object we got earlier containing our
tagged email we go ahead and then
call the query function and execute it
and what the last parameter we passed to
query specifies the output of the query
that we're expecting in this case a four
Tuple consisting of the of the tags that
one positions one four five and seven in
the tags list and then those correspond
to the from email date time and two
emails and so though we have a method
called display tuples on the tag message
which displays the results from our
query and in this case you'll see that
there's three there's actually three
lines that come back from the query
and we're only really expecting two and
the reason we got an extra one is
because we have a duplicate row that
happens with
the two and male 2 appear let's see
here's the mail to and here's the two
and that's why we're getting an extra
one for this last one so we'd seek to be
able to eliminate that and so we're
going to make to illustrate that we can
make very we're going to illustrate
user-defined user-defined predicates
which allow us to Define our own
predicate which we can then call on our
query to be able to get rid of that
extra couple
so the way we do that is we have a
user-defined predicate called not
preceded by mail it's going to take a
single
um a single tag in this parameter and
that's going to become the locals method
of this label expression that we passed
to query UDP to the to Define our
user-defined functions and the way
that's going to work is it's going to
look at the text of the document it's
going to look at the location of that it
received as this parameter it's going to
take the start of that that start of
that text it's going to back up four
characters and it's going to check to
see if the word mail appears before 2.
and if it does it's going to return
false that's what the not symbol
indicates here so now we've added This
this term into our query and then we can
go ahead and execute the query and sure
enough our last cup our extra Tuple
removed
the second example is we want to extract
illustrate how you can extract the table
from electric bills
um we commonly want to be able to grab
tables from PDF documents and so this is
going to illustrate how we can actually
grab just the text from this table in a
in a dictionary that we're ultimately
going to get and we're going to try to
read just this text and discard all the
rest
the red
material we're going to discard later
and then the blue is the strings that
we're going to be able to reference in
our query to be able to try to do the
operation we need to do
so the first step as before we're going
to just read the text from our bill in
this case we got we use PDF to text with
the layout option to be able to go ahead
and preserve the layout produce a text
document corresponding to the PDF which
we then read into our code and then this
is what we see and we can actually see
let's see here a minute this should
correspond quite closely to our PDF that
we see here the text
of the mail corresponds quite well
I want to leave this here A second
so the first task we want to do is we
want to get rid of the column that has
all this stuff on the far right which
we're basically going to just get rid of
it as noise and the way we're going to
do it is we're going to look for a
column that contains the string the
total electric charges shown in the
electric
and so we're going to try to find that
string find the column that contains
that string and we're going to tag all
the text that appears within that column
of that table as noise with a noise tag
and then we're going to delete it by
replacing all the text with the noise
tag
and then we're going to have the result
from that
so we create our tagger object as before
we look for this the electric column we
tag it as noise with tag list here
and then we replace the noise with the
empty string and then sure enough as you
look here you'll see that the right hand
side has had that column removed
okay so next step is to go ahead and
just focus in on the green text that
we're interested in for our table we're
going to do that by grabbing some extra
extra functionality we need to do and
we're going to look for the strings
current and electric charges similar to
the way Martha Illustrated in her
example and we're going to try to find
the text that's between including
current but before electric charges so
the first thing we're going to do is we
have a line regular expression of a line
a line regular expression that allow us
to tag lines with tag re so we'll be
able to get individual lines we're going
to get the location of the line that
contains current
that happens before electric charges
and then we're going to select a text
from current up to but not including
electric charges and then we're going to
choose the shortest the shortest the
shortest segment of text that does that
to avoid grabbing multiple Pages if we
have it
so the way we do that is we create the
Tigers before we tag the lines
we're going to use the query
we have three tags in this case
and we're going to query all those three
tags and we're gonna
grab them execute the query and we get
back the text that corresponds to just
the green part of the table
the last step is to go ahead and grab
the text and be able to convert it into
a form that's easiest for the computer
to consume and so we have a nice
function to be able to do this called
get table and we're going to tell get
cable that the top two rows of our our
text are the are the header it's very
clever it uses the header and the
location of the header columns to be
able to find the individual cells below
that table and goes ahead and creates a
list of dictionaries where the keys of
the dictionary are the headers and the
values of each item in the dictionary
corresponds to the values appearing at
that row of the table
I don't know so in conclusion what we've
done is we provided a tool for data
extraction from text we've allowed that
data extraction to happen in a
declarative manner so we're not just
having to do a sequence of code in
Python where we're having to understand
the frequencing we just say exactly what
we want with tags and queries and we use
this to provide functionality for the
most commonly used data abstraction
packs what does this allow us to do it
allows us to specify the new
functionality at a high level of
instruction and this really helps when
Upstream text format changes it's a real
pain to change code this way we just
change our query very simply to be able
to reflect the new formatted text
and lastly this facilitates maintenance
and data extraction code this code is
short easy to understand write and
change
questions
thank you very much uh we are taking
questions now
um are your slides going to be available
uh to view later
uh the slides are available on the
GitHub in the GitHub repo so you can you
can download those and then look at them
there
and I put the uh
the URL for GitHub here
and I think you can just go to this this
URL on GitHub and it'll be able to have
a slides underneath the uh next to the
readme file on GitHub
um
oh sorry can we add that link to uh the
Discord please
sure uh let me find
I don't have Discord at the moment
unfortunately let me see if I can put it
in the chat we can edit yeah
yeah that's fine let's see here uh
see if I could actually go there Wall
Street
yeah
this is the slide deck here actually
yes I got it
okay now it's um on the comment section
oh
okay any other questions
okay um
can see questions
we can sort of wrap up here
so
thank you very much David and Martha and
uh the link is now posted
and
we are going to stop here and there's
going to be uh the keynote next
see you later okay thank you thank you
very much